ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen nach
einer durchgemachten Nacht von Sonntag
auf Montag haben sich die Spitzen der
Koalition heute noch mal getroffen um an
viele wichtige Themen die sie sich als
Regierung vorgenommen haben endlich ein
Häkchen machen zu können zum Beispiel
beim Straßenbau und beim Thema Heizungen
und nachdem es jetzt fast den ganzen Tag
gedauert hat sehen wir dass es nun doch
zum Ende dieses Tages hin Statements
geben soll und dazu geben wir live ab in
den Bundestag nach Berlin auf die
fraktionsebenen denn dort sehen wir
haben sich die Spitzen von SPD FDP und
Grünen jetzt vor den Mikrofonen
versammelt
und wir gehen rüber nach Berlin
ich will ihn trotzdem sagen ich und ich
glaube wir drei stehen hier hoch
zufrieden man kann zweieinhalb Tage
verhandeln wenn man dann die garantiert
dass viele Dinge in diesem Land
schneller laufen werden dass wir sie
schneller Regeln und dass wir insgesamt
als Koalition in großen Schritten unsere
Richtung Zukunft und Stärke in
Deutschland bewegen und das ist das
Ergebnis dass wir Ihnen jetzt gerne aus
den koalitions aus dem
Koalitionsausschuss in den letzten
zweieinhalb Tagen vorstellen wollen wir
haben uns beschäftigt mit der Frage was
müssen wir tun damit Deutschland ein
modernes Land ist
Infrastrukturprojekte vorangebracht
werden wie die Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energie
vorangetrieben wird alles das hat uns
umgetrieben wir hatten im letzten Jahr
als Koalition eine Agenda die darauf
fokussiert war das Land durch eine
schwere Krise zu bringen das haben wir
getan mit drei entlassungspaketen mit
den Gas und Strompreis Bremsen auch mit
einer Stärkung der Bundeswehr und jetzt
ging es aber um die nächsten Schritt wie
schaffen wir die Transformation wie
schaffen wir den Schritt nach vorne
und dazu haben wir ein ganzes Bündel an
wichtigen Maßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
als Koalition das was für mich sehr
bedeutend ist dass wir bei allen großen
Infrastrukturprojekten dieses Landes
Vorankommen eine massive Stärkung der
Bahn die Stärkung der Straße die
Stärkung der Netze und sämtlichen
Bereichen auch der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien alles das spielt
in dem Beschlüssen des
Koalitionsausschusses aus den letzten
Stunden eine große Rolle wir fokussieren
auch darauf Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren so wie wir das im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt haben
massiv zu beschleunigen das waren
Diskussionen wo wir ringen mussten das
sage ich in aller Klarheit aber etwas wo
wir dafür sorgen werden dass das
Deutschland Tempo dass wir schon beim
Ausbau der lng-terminals gesehen haben
also endlich eine andere Geschwindigkeit
auch im Vergleich zu den letzten Jahren
eine andere Geschwindigkeit mit der als
Politik gemacht werden kann dass das auf
sämtliche Bereich auch der
Infrastrukturplanung angewandt werden
kann
wir haben auch darüber gesprochen wie
wir das Klimaschutzgesetz auf dass wir
als Sozialdemokratien Sozialdemokraten
sehr stolz sind wie wir dieses
Klimaschutzgesetz noch effizienter
gestalten können damit das große Ziel
dass wir im Koalitionsvertrag verabredet
haben nämlich Deutschland bis 2045
klimaneutral zu machen das
Klimaschutzgesetz so umzubauen dass
dieses Ziel noch besser gelingen kann
und der letzte Punkt den ich von meiner
Seite ansprechen will natürlich hat uns
auch die Frage der wärmewende
beschäftigt dazu sind in den letzten
Tagen ja Vorschläge von Robert Habeck
und klarer geibitz gemacht worden wir
haben das Ziel dass wir politisch in
Koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben noch
mal bestärkt in der Sitzung des
Koalitionsausschusses das ist ein
gemeinsames Ziel dass wir mit dieser
Regierung erreichen wollen und trotzdem
haben wir natürlich wahrgenommen wie
Unsicherheiten in den letzten Wochen
waren wie Unsicherheit auch in der
Bevölkerung gewachsen ist und deswegen
die ganze klare Aussage aus dem
Koalitionsausschuss dass wir diese
Unsicherheiten sehen dass wir dafür
sorgen dass soziale Gerechtigkeit auch
herrschen wird und dass niemand in
diesem Land im Stich gelassen wird
vielen Dank
auch von mir einen guten Abend das waren
auf gar keinen Fall einfache
Verhandlungen und es war ein Ringen an
sehr vielen Stellen ich möchte mal auch
sprechen kommen woran das liegt in den
letzten Jahren ist in diesem Land vieles
wiegen geblieben und wir als Ampel haben
uns jetzt daran gemacht dieses Land zu
modernisieren das was auf der Strecke
geblieben ist bei der
planungsbeschleunigung oder auch beim
Klimaschutz endlich anzugehen das ist
zwischen drei Parteien kein einfacher
Aushandlungsprozess und ich würde
vielleicht sogar sagen und deshalb haben
wir uns auch ein bisschen Zeit dafür
genommen dass stellvertreten für die
Gesellschaft in dieser Ampel Konflikte
Fragen Interessen miteinander
ausverhandelt werden das ist nicht
einfach das geht für jeden Nachnahme
Zumutungen einher aber am Ende haben wir
uns jetzt Ampel auf diesen Weg gemacht
und gehen endlich auch Strukturreformen
an Lars hat es gerade schon gesagt das
letzte Jahr war sehr stark geprägt durch
Krisenbewältigung jetzt gehen wir die
Modernisierung und die Strukturreform an
um dieses Land voranzubringen und ich
bin froh dass wir Teil einer Regierung
sind die damit jetzt anfängt die sich
jetzt auch wirklich auf den Weg gemacht
hat sich nicht einfach macht sondern
auch die schwierigen Aushandlungen auf
sich nimmt um am Ende in der Sache
wirklich auch voranzukommen und dabei
möchte ich auf drei Themen besonderen zu
sprechen kommen ein starkes Thema in
diesem Koalitionsausschuss war das Thema
Klimaschutz und Verkehr auch hier eines
wahrscheinlich der kompliziertesten um
im Klimaschutz voranzukommen und wir
haben uns darauf geeinigt die Bahn hat
einen Investitionsbedarf in den nächsten
Jahren bis 2027 von 45 Milliarden Euro
das ist ein riesen Paket das ist ein
riesen Bedarf und wir machen uns jetzt
daran dass aufzudecken darin rein zu
investieren und deshalb werden wir
gemeinsam als Ampel die Lkw-Maut ab dem
nächsten Jahr erhöhen und das Geld was
dort neu reinkommt wird zu 80% in den
Ausbau der Schiene in einem moderne Bahn
fließen damit wir an diese 45 Milliarden
rankommen und jetzt wirklich auch eine
offensive bei der Bahn starten zweitens
planungsbeschleunigung wir haben uns
alle vorgenommen wir wollen teuer werden
und das ist richtig und das ist wichtig
so wir wollen schneller werden beim
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energie beim
Stromnetzen bei den Schienen und ja bei
den Straßen das war für uns kein
einfacher Punkt aber werden eine
begrenzte Anzahl von Straßen im Ausbau
beschleunigen zu werden das mit den
Ländern abgestimmt ist wir haben uns
gleichzeitig darauf geeinigt dass wir in
Zukunft verpflichtend beim Neubau von
Autobahnen die Solar Möglichkeiten der
Solarenergie am Rand nutzen werden das
heißt wir starten eine riesige
solar-ausbau Offensive verbinden
Klimaschutz mit Straßenbau und in
Zukunft sollen Deutschland kein neuer
Kilometer Autobahn mehr gebaut werden
und auch beim Ausbau ohne dass diese
Platz auch genutzt wird für die
erneuerbaren Energien und der dritte
Punkt Last klingbar hatten schon
angesprochen ich glaube vor etwas
weniger als einem Jahr standen wir schon
mal der gleichen Dreierkonstellation
hier das war nach dem zweiten
Entlastungspaket und hat uns darauf
geeinigt die Wärme werden jetzt wirklich
anzugehen und bei
neuen Heizungen auf klimafreundliche
Alternativen zu setzen und jetzt haben
wir uns gemeinsam als Koalition
entschieden diesen Weg auch jetzt
anzugehen das Gebäude Energiegesetz zu
reformieren auf klimafreundliche
Alternativen bei neuen Heizung zu setzen
und es ist klar das ist für viele
Menschen diesen Land auch nicht einfach
zu tragen das sehen wir deshalb werden
wir dabei sein sozialen Ausgleich sorgen
man kann sagen niemand wird im Stich
gelassen
ja meine Damen und Herren das waren
intensive Beratungen im
Koalitionsausschuss an ganz neues Gefühl
der Koalitionsausschuss ist zu Ende und
es war noch hell oder noch nicht wieder
hell sondern wir haben am Ende eines
Tages einen guten Abschluss gefunden wir
hatten viele Fragen miteinander zu
besprechen ich darf sagen es hat Freude
gemacht sich auch einmal vertieft
auszutauschen die Gelegenheit haben wir
uns auch genommen zwischendurch konnte
man lesen über was wir angeblich
diskutiert haben ich darf Ihnen
versichern wir haben
öfter über die Dinge diskutiert von
denen niemand von ihnen wusste dass wir
darüber gesprochen haben und teilweise
haben wir gelesen worüber wir angeblich
gestritten hätten obwohl diese Dinge
niemals thematisiert worden sind von
irgendjemanden das war also auch ein
gewisses unterhaltungsmoment während
dieser Tage
wir hatten in den letzten
Wochen Monaten und auch noch im
Koalitionsvertrag offene Enden die
geschlossen werden mussten dazu war
dieser vertiefter Austausch erforderlich
auch bei Punkten auf die die Kolleginnen
und der Kollege eingegangen sind hatten
wir ja aus den Koalitionsvertrag
herauskommt noch
konkretisierungsbedarf den wir jetzt
geschlossen haben man kann also für mich
zumindestens so zusammenfassen man
schweigt sich auseinander und man
diskutiert sich zusammen ich glaube das
ist das Gefühl was wir als
Koalitionspartner am Ende dieses
intensiven Beratungsprozesses Teilen ich
will von meiner Seite auch drei Punkte
ansprechen der erste Punkt ist das Klima
Schutzgesetz sie wissen dass von der
großen Koalition seiner Zeit
beschlossene Klimaschutzgesetz sieht vor
das in jedem Jahr jeder einzelne Sektor
unseres Lebens und Wirtschaftens
bestimmte
CO2-Minderungsziele erreichen muss
das ist sehr bürokratisch und führt
teilweise auch zu in der Praxis nicht
umsetzbaren Ergebnissen und wir haben
uns jetzt darauf verständigt dass
Klimaschutzgesetz in diesem Punkt
konzeptionell zu verändern und den
Auftrag des Koalitionsvertrages
umzusetzen zukünftig schauen wir nach
vorne nicht mehr jährlich sondern bis
zum Beispiel zum Jahr 2030 und wir
sorgen dafür dass die Sektoren sich
gegenseitig helfen können das heißt die
reine sektororientierung überwinden wir
haben eine langfristige
sektorübergreifende Perspektive man
könnte also sagen im Klimaschutzgesetz
öffnen wir jetzt den Raum für
marktwirtschaftlichere Ergebnisse um zu
einem effektiveren Klimaschutz zu kommen
zum zweiten war das Thema Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren ein ganz großes
uns gemeinsam am Herzen liegendes Thema
das betrifft zum Beispiel den Bereich
der Schiene und wir wollen das Netz ja
modernisieren dazu werden auch Mittel
bereitgestellt den CO2 auf Belag auf die
Lkw-Maut wollen wir sehr überwiegend
dafür verwenden auch in die Schiene zu
investieren da werden wir auch die
Verfahren beschleunigen auch der Bereich
der Straße ist jetzt in den Blick
genommen wir werden bei Engpässen die
wir haben
ein überragendes öffentliches Interesse
bestimmen gesetzlich festlegen dass die
engpassstellen im überragenden
öffentlichen Interesse sind das betrifft
autobahnprojekte in Deutschland die
jetzt im überragenden gesetzlichen
Interesse sind wir werden auch darüber
hinaus viele Vorhaben in unserem Land
beschleunigen durch einen echten
Paradigmenwechsel in Naturschutz und das
ist finde ich von der praktischen
Wirkung kaum zu überschätzen bislang
werden viele Vorhaben Straßen neue
Produktionsanlagen erneuerbare Energie
dadurch gebremst dass man Flächen
kompensieren muss also wer eine Fläche
in Anspruch nimmt muss eine neue Fläche
bieten um einen naturschutzausgleich zu
haben das überwinden wir zukünftig wird
es möglich sein auch durch eine
Geldleistung diese Kompensation
vorzunehmen das ist für die wirkliche
Realisierung von Vorhaben ein
Paradigmenwechsel das trägt zusätzlich
dazu bei dass von Schiene über
erneuerbare Energien
Produktionsstandorte bis hin zum
Straßenbau viel mehr in Deutschland
passieren kann als bisher sind
wirklicher Paradigmenwechsel im
Interesse des Naturschutzes und der
wirklichen Beschleunigung
unterschiedlichster privater wir
öffentlicher Vorhaben der dritte Punkt
den ich nennen will das ist die die
technologiefreiheit hier haben wir einen
großen gemeinsamen Schritt gemacht wir
stärken den CO2 freien Verkehr nicht nur
durch die Schiene sondern indem wir
einen richtigen Hochlauf der
Elektromobilität organisieren
ladesäulen-infrastruktur und anderes
mehr nachdem wir jetzt auf europäischer
Ebene ja eine neue Fahrzeugkategorie
schaffen mit den
Fahrzeugen die mit synthetischen
CO2-neutralen Kraftstoffen betankt
werden werden wir jetzt auch national
eine Strategie entwickeln wie wir die in
die Praxis bekommen mit Forschung und
mit Import dieser Kraftstoffe mit der
Anpassung der rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen bis hin zur Anpassung
des Steuerrechts dass alle Fahrzeuge die
bilanziell CO2 neutral sind in einer
gleichen Weise behandelt werden zur
Technologie Freiheit gehört auch die
wärmewende auf die die Kolleginnen und
der Kollege eingegangen sind völlig
richtig was beide gesagt haben wir
fördern die Bürgerinnen und Bürger bei
der Modernisierung Ihrer Heizung mit
einem Programm aus dem Klima-
der Bundesregierung dabei das
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben zu finalisieren
und entsprechende Anpassungen gegenüber
den ersten Ideen vorzunehmen und diese
Anpassungen stehen unter dem Gedanken
der Technologie Freiheit es wird darauf
geachtet werden dass eben ein
technologieoffener Ansatz verfolgt wird
wird eine Reihe von unterschiedlichen
erfüllungsoptionen geben zum Beispiel
der Betrieb mit grünen und blauem
Wasserstoff oder Biomasse außerdem
sollen fossiler Heizungen weiterhin
zugelassen werden die Wasserstoff oder
grüne Gase ready sind sofern es eine
entsprechende Planung für das Gasnetz
gibt es wird keine Austauschpflicht
geben für bestehende Heizungen sondern
lediglich Vorgaben für neu eingebaute
Heizungen und wir werden bei bestimmten
alters-zeiträume werden wir ebenfalls
schaffen das ist gerade work and
progress das läuft gerade innerhalb der
Bundesregierung aber wir sind sicher
dass dieses gemeinsam getragene wichtige
Vorhaben der wärmewende dadurch
wirtschaftlich vernünftig und sozial
tragbar für alle in Deutschland
gestaltet werden wird insgesamt ein sehr
erfolgreicher Koalitionsausschuss wo
jeder jeden Punkt gut vertreten kann und
jeder auch noch einen speziellen Punkt
hat über den sie oder er sich besonders
freut
diese Beschlüsse für den Haushalt das
war ja vorher schon Problem gewesen
haben die darüber gesprochen das klingt
so als ob zum Beispiel für die Schiene
dort mehr Geld aus dem Tisch gelegt
werden
sollen
immer betont das Koalitionsausschuss
anders verlaufen
soll ist diese Regierung jetzt
angekommen miteinander
ich habe kurz zu Beginn des
Koalitionsausschusses über die Situation
der Haushaltsberatung und die aktuelle
Lage gesprochen das war gut eine halbe
Stunde dir da die wir darauf verwendet
haben was jetzt die Beschlüsse angeht
die wir getroffen haben haben diese
keine direkte Wirkung für den
Bundeshaushalt bei der Stärkung der
Schiene haben wir jetzt konkret
verabredet dass wir etwas beim CO2
Aufschlag bei der Lkw-Maut machen
darüber hinaus sind die
Haushaltsberatungen abzuwarten und bei
dem Programm zur finanziellen
Unterstützung der wärmewende haben wir
uns auf den Klima und
transformationsform gestützt auch da
sind dann über den Klima und
Transformation gegebenenfalls
hinausgehender Regelungen Gegenstand der
Haushaltsberatung
sie haben Rechte winke ich habe das
damals übrigens gemeinsam mit dem
damaligen Generalsekretär der FDP und
dem Bundesgeschäftsführer der Grünen ja
ein paar Mal betont dass wir nicht zu
diesem Modus der Nachtsitzung kommen
wollten das hat nicht funktioniert an
dieser Stelle das haben sie alle
mitgekriegt und gemerkt es hatte auch
damit zu tun dass wir eben gesagt haben
es gibt regierungsverpflichtungen
gestern die deutschen niederländischen
regierungskonsultation der Bundeskanzler
heute auch ein paar mal unterwegs war
der Verpflichtung als Kanzler hatte da
haben wir dann in kleineren Gruppen
weiter getagt aber wollten natürlich
dann auch gemeinsam mit dem
Bundeskanzler in anderen
Kabinettsmitgliedern immer auch die
Ergebnisse abschließen aber es hat
länger gedauert das hat mit einer
Situation zu tun die sie selbst auch in
den letzten Wochen verfolgen konnten es
gab einiges was geklärt werden mussten
und ich habe es einleitend gesagt das
sind große weitgehende Beschlüsse zu
Modernisierung des Landes die wir
getroffen haben wir legen eine gute
Grundlage dafür dass Deutschland ein
starkes erfolgreiches Land bleibt und
dass die
Arbeitsplätze die Infrastruktur der
Zukunft auch geschaffen werden und da
hat das ein oder andere eben länger
gedauert in der Erklärung das sollte
nicht der Regelfall werden bei Koalition
zur Schüssen aber an dieser Stelle was
wichtig und wir haben auch sehr bewusst
gesagt wir brechen nicht irgendwann
unter Zeitdruck ab und dann kommt es
vielleicht an der einen oder anderen
Stelle zu komischen unter Druck
entstandenen Beschlüssen sondern wir
haben immer klar gemacht wir nehmen uns
die Zeit die wir brauchen um diese
wirklich weitreichenden notwendigen
Beschlüsse zum Modernisierung des Landes
auch zu treffen
zwei Fragen an alle drei wenn ich darf
es hat ja vor diesen Koalitionsausschuss
heftige gegenseitige Vorwürfe gegeben es
sind zum vertrauensbruck haben Sie das
Gefühl dass dieses Vertrauen jetzt
wieder vollkommen hergestellt ist und
er ging bei sie haben von vom neuen
Deutschland Tempo geredet das wird dann
die Frage von Herrn Rinker an jetzt
haben wir drei Tage verhandelt ist dass
das neue
koalitionstempo angefangen sich
willst du anfangen was die erste Frage
sehr gerne starten also ich glaube der
Ton war ziemlich ruppig innerhalb der
letzten Woche dass es keine Frage da
müssen wir uns auch alle drei an die
eigene Nase fassen bzw Nasen unsere
eigenen Parteien ich habe es ja zu
Beginn schon mal etwas gesagt ich glaube
wir sind eine Konstellation die erste
3er Bundesregierung wenn man vielleicht
bei der Union mal bestimmte
Voraussetzungen außen vor lässt dir
gemeinsam gesellschaftliche Konflikte
aushandelt unter sich und das braucht
manchmal Zeit ich glaube wir haben es
immer geschafft auch wenn ich mir das
letzte Jahr anschau die
Krisenbewältigung die Entlastungspaket
der am Ende da wo gehandelt werden
musste auch zu handeln und wenn es
wieder gezeigt dass wir es auch hier
schaffen in Zukunft kriegen wir
vielleicht auch im Weg dorthin nicht nur
im Ergebnis gut gemeinsam hin ein
Beispiel wurde ja zum Beispiel genannt
Christian Lindner ist darauf eingegangen
beim Klimaschutzgesetz da hatten wir
unterschiedliche Positionen haben uns am
Ende auf einen Kompromiss geeinigt wo
klar ist die Sektor Ziele bleiben
bestehen als Prinzip des
klimaschutzgesetzes es wird aber
einfacher sich untereinander zu helfen
und wir gehen mehr auf eine Prognose das
andere Beispiel war der Ausbau der
Infrastruktur in diesem Land wo wir
massiv was hinbekommen haben bei den
Erneuerbaren beiden Schienen wo wir
glaube ich alle wissen wie schwierig die
Aushandlung zu Straßen war und am Ende
ein Kompromiss gefunden haben mit einer
begrenzten Anzahl mit Abstimmung mit den
Ländern und vor allem aber auch mit der
Verbindung alles was gebaut wird in
diesem Land in Zukunft alles was ein
Straße Autobahn gebaut wird wird mit
erneuerbarer Energien mit Solar
verbunden ich glaube das zeigt so ein
bisschen niemand hat sich einfach
gemacht aber am Ende kriegt man das auch
hin aus den unterschiedlichen
Perspektiven ich würde mal sagen
Ergebnisse zu erzielen die vielleicht
besser werden als wenn wir alle nur mit
uns alleine verhandeln würden
also weil sie das deutsche Tempo
angesprochen haben ja es hat lange
gedauert und Ricarda hat es gerade
gesagt es gab in den Wochen davor auch
einige Streitpunkte die sich aufgetürmt
hatten über die wir selbstverständlich
auch reden mussten aber am Ende sage ich
Ihnen das was wir jetzt in zweieinhalb
Tagen geschafft haben es ist die
Grundlage dafür dass wir ein
wirtschaftlich ein ökonomisch starkes
Land haben in Zukunft dass wir viele
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
endlich beschleunigen konnten das über
den großen Infrastruktur Aufgaben dieses
Landes vorankommt dass wir beim
Klimaschutz Vorankommen dass wir an
vielen anderen Stellen auch Durchbrüche
hatten mit denen sie alle und
ehrlicherweise ich auch vor ein paar
Tagen noch nicht gerechnet hatten
beispielsweise bei der Frage wie wir
Naturschutz neu aufstellen in diesem
Land und das wirklich in einer wirksamen
Art und Weise und ich hatte schon das
Gefühl und da will ich Ricarda absolut
zustimmen dass wir es dann auch schaffen
gesellschaftliche Aushandlungsprozesse
zum Beispiel zwischen der Frage Ökonomie
und Klimaschutz zwischen zwischen Fragen
von Infrastruktur ausbauen Naturschutz
dass wir es als Koalition auch sind die
gesellschaftliche Aushandlungsprozesse
hinbekommen und zwar das wichtig dass
wir nicht rhetorisch Dinge verkleistern
sondern wir haben uns Zeit genommen sie
wirklich auszudiskutieren und das ganze
eigentlich über den sämtlichen Zeitraum
in einer absolut konstruktiven Art und
Weise ich habe auch kann ich mich
Christian Lindner nur anschließen vieles
gelesen während dieser zweieinhalb Tage
was absolut nichts mit dem zu tun hatte
was im Raum selbst stattgefunden hat
aber ich bin froh dass wir uns die Zeit
genommen haben dass wir jetzt diese
Ergebnisse haben und das wird dem Land
sehr gut tun
okay das waren drei Fragen vielen Dank
danke danke
ja soweit also die Pressekonferenz der
Parteivorsitzenden von SPD Grünen und
FDP im Bundestag in Berlin es wurde noch
mal darauf eingegangen dass man sehr
lange gerungen hat aber wie FDP-Chef
Lindner sagte es hat in Teilen auch
Freude gemacht sich so intensiv
auszutauschen wenn ich mal in die
Kommentare gucke dann sehe ich
viel Kritik daran dass es so lange
gedauert hat auch an den Ergebnissen
Sun catido schreibt z.B über Youtube
viele Worte aber keine genauen Aussagen
wir möchten gerne weiter eure Fragen und
Kommentare mit in die Sendung reinnehmen
also schreibt gerne in die Chats oder
auch per Mail an die bekannte
E-Mail-Adresse und über die Aussagen die
getroffen wurden und auch nicht
getroffen wurden sprechen wir mit meiner
Kollegin Nicole Diekmann aus dem
zdf-hauptstadt Studio da ist sie hallo
Nicole du hast das äh die Statements mit
verfolgt die Antworten der drei
Parteivorsitzenden was sind denn die
wesentlichen Punkte für dich gewesen
ich fange mal damit an was die
wesentlichen Punkte für die drei
Parteivorsitzenden waren ich zitiere es
hat Freude gemacht sich vertieft
auszutauschen in den letzten Jahren ist
viel liegen geblieben das waren so
Aussagen ach so eine noch ein sehr
erfolgreicher Koalitionsausschuss sei
das gewesen da ist man jetzt also
wirklich sehr bemüht gewesen diese
vergangenen zwei Tage fast drei Tage
zweieinhalb Tage waren es ähm ein
bisschen auch zu verklären oder
zumindest in etwas umzuwandeln was er
eigentlich was sehr gutes war denn
Friedrich Merz und Jungs Fraktionschef
war nicht der einzige heute der das Wort
Regierungskrise in den Mund genommen hat
denn mit jeder Stunde die sich dieser
Ausschuss zog fragte man sich ja doch in
was für einem Zustand ist dies der
Ampelkoalition eigentlich immer zu den
Inhalten ähm was ich mir ja auf meinen
vielen Zetteln markiert habe ist
Ricarda lang durfte das die Grünen
Chefin verkünden die Lkw-Maut wird in
der Höhe mit ab kommendem Jahr schon und
80 Prozent des Geldes dass dadurch
zusätzlich eingenommen werden sollen
eine Summe gibt es nicht sie hat auch
nicht gesagt um wie viel die Lkw-Maut
erhöht werden wird 80 Prozent jedenfalls
des Geldes das dann zusätzlich reinkommt
gehen in den Ausbau und auch in die
dringenden Reformen bei der Bahn die das
sagte Ricarda lang auch bis 2027 satte
45 Milliarden Euro braucht das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt der nächste Punkt ist
das war ja der große Streit vor allem
zwischen FDP und Grünen der erinnern uns
der grüne Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck war vergangene Woche heute genau
vor einer Woche bei den Kollegen in den
Tagesthemen und hat da sehr von jeder
gezogen von Vertrauensbruch gesprochen
weil ein Gesetzentwurf aus deinem Hause
wie er sagte geliebt worden war an die
Bild-Zeitung darin geht es um die
sogenannte wärmewende um den Ausbau von
die Gasheizungen von Ölheizungen die ab
kommendem Jahr so sah sein Entwurf vor
nicht mehr eingebaut werden dürfen keine
neuen das hat dafür sehr viel Ärger und
viele Fragezeichen auch in der
Bevölkerung
geführt und sagte ich fange noch mal mit
Ricarda lang an auch darüber habe man in
den vergangenen Tagen sehr intensiv
gesprochen ich zitiere sie mit den
Worten niemand wird im Stich gelassen
konkreter wurde sie aber nicht ein
bisschen mehr konnte dazu beisteuern
dann FDP-Chef Lindner der sagte fossile
Heizungen werden weiter zugelassen
allerdings nur wenn sie das läuft bei
der FDP im Moment unter dem was wird
technologiefreiheit ready sind wir er
sagte für
klimaneutrale Stoffe und so sagt ja auch
bei bestimmten Alters und
Einkommensgruppen werde man für einen
sozialen Ausgleich sorgen dass ist die
berühmte die in ihrem Haus sitzt und
noch eine alte Ölheizung hat das war so
das Beispiel das in den vergangenen
Tagen immer diskutiert worden war was
machen solche Leute wenn auf die jetzt
also der Einbau einer neuen ähm sehr
teueren Heizung zukommt ein weiterer
Punkt den ich sehr wichtig finde ist das
mache ich noch mal schnell ist das
Christian Lindner sagte die
sektorenziele die berühmten also
Klimaschutzgesetz noch aus der Gruppe
stammend
diese Sektoren Ziele das heißt jeder
Bereich
euch in der
das Ministerium muss in seinem Bereich
gucken wie hoch sind die CO2-Ausstöße
und muss binnen einem Jahres bestimmte
Vorgaben erfüllen das hat man jetzt
gekippt das ist ein riesen Schritt man
will jetzt sagt der Lindner nicht mehr
nach Jahren schauen sondern bis zum
Beispiel 2030 und da könnten die
Sektoren sagte er einander helfen
Nicole viele Themen die Du da gerade
noch mal wiedergegeben hast auf die man
sich offenbar einigen konnte das heißt
es ist also schon auch viel Konkretes am
Ende dabei rausgekommen hier fragen sich
viele Userinnen und User ist das denn
alles tatsächlich jetzt ein
Paradigmenwechsel auch das Wort hat der
Christian Lindner benutzt und du hast es
auch erwähnt ja mein schreibt zum
Beispiel über Youtube Lindner sprach von
Paradigmenwechsel inwiefern stellt das
Vorhaben der Koalition einen echten
Wechsel da
ja Lindner hat das sogar mehrfach gesagt
und zwar vor allem als es um
planungsbeschleunigungsverfahren ging da
gab es nämlich auch sehr viel Streit in
den letzten Wochen dass Deutschland
Tempo sogenannte ist Last klingball
besagt es soll alles einfach schneller
gehen oder ganz viel schneller gehen
Bürokratie abgebaut werden und neue
Verfahren neue Projekte viel schneller
angekurbelt werden und da war der
kernstreitpunkt auch da wieder zwischen
grün und FDP welche Verfahren sollen
denn beschleunigt werden die Grünen
sagten es geht vor allem um den Ausbau
von erneuerbaren Energien das muss
schneller gehen und eben der Ausbau der
Schienennetze des öffentlichen
Personennahverkehrs und auch
Fernverkehrs da sagte aber die FDP es
geht auch im Straßen und Autobahnen und
auch da hat man sich jetzt ich sag mal
geeinigt Christian Lindner wirkte da
sehr zufrieden das kann man auch
verstehen das wird in Zukunft auch für
Autobahnen gelten das ist der eine
Paradigmenwechsel und der andere ist
wenn gebaut wird bisher ist das
schlummern muss eine sogenannte
flächenkompensation leisten wird hier
gebaut und in den Naturschutz
eingegriffen muss an der anderen Stelle
eine gleichwertige Fläche zur Verfügung
gestellt werden um den Naturschutz zu
gewährleisten das soll in Zukunft
wegfallen das soll mit Geld ausgeglichen
werden können und das ist schon ein
riesen Schritt da fragt genau dazu ein
Usernamens fdde ist es nicht kritisch
dass ich Unternehmen beim Naturschutz
rauskaufen können und ich will nicht zu
viel reininterpretieren wir haben
Ricarda lang gesehen aber an der Stelle
wo Lindner das gesagt hat und sie neben
ihm stand und ihm so nach oben zu gucken
musste und das unkommentiert stehen
gelassen hat was er da gesagt hat man
hat schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl
gehabt dass sie gehabt dass sie ein
bisschen leidet bei dem Punkt
ja ich habe auch gedacht als ich Lindner
hörte und Ricarda langsam das ist eine
Kröte die die Grünen schlucken mussten
das ist so ich war da lang hat versucht
da auch kommunikativ jetzt ist ja immer
wichtig auch wie man Beschlüsse nach
außen verkauft
einen Kompromiss der auch für die Grünen
gut ausgegangen ist darzustellen indem
sie gesagt hat ja aber mit jedem
Kilometer neuer Autobahn die in Zukunft
in Deutschland gebaut wird wird an die
Seitenränder dieser Autobahn werden
solarfällen gebaut das heißt dadurch
wird werden erneuerbare Energien auch
gleichzeitig generiert ja das ähm ist
natürlich im Sinne der Grünen aber wie
gesagt Christian Lindner redet von einem
Paradigmenwechsel Ricarda lang schaut
dabei als hätte sie Zahnschmerzen das
hat schon Gründe warum sie das tut er
hat die FDP sich auf weiten Strecken
ziemlich durchgesetzt das heißt man
könnte dem Zuschauer namens Moby Recht
geben die Grünen lassen sich schon
wieder über den Tisch ziehen und sagen
auch noch danke
oder ist das jetzt so direkt nach diesem
Statement zu viel gesagt und man wird
feststellen dass sich die Grünen doch in
vielen Punkten durchgesetzt haben und
auch die FDP viel Federn lassen musste
in dieser Einigung
ich würde auf den ersten Blick sagen
dass die FDP durchaus ihre Punkte
gemacht hat man muss aber auch immer
wissen es wird nie eine Einigung
verkündet werden wenn da drei
Parteivorsitzende stehen bei denen eine
der Parteien wirklich komplett das
Gesicht verliert dieser 80 Prozent der
oder diese Erhöhung der Lkw-Maut zum
Beispiel von denen dann 80% in die Bahn
gehen sollen das ist schon klarer Punkt
für die Grünen aber man muss natürlich
immer auch austarieren wer ist der
kleinste Koalitionspartner wer ist der
größte ist die SPD und wer ist der
zweitgrößte das sind die Grünen und da
dann immer mal wieder schauen wer hat
eigentlich wem wir sehr die Hand
gereicht interessant ist in dem
Zusammenhang auch dass die Bild die
heute dann doch ein bisschen mehr wusste
als wir alle anderen es ist sehr sehr
wenig nach außen getrunken aber das
bisschen was die Bild erfahren hat ist
dass es wohl die konfliktieren ja auf
der einen Seite SPD und FDP da
in diese letzten zweieinhalb Jahren und
auf der anderen Seite die Grünen
jetzt muss man bei allem natürlich auch
du hast es gerade gesagt das sind drei
Partner die SPD nicht vergessen und die
soziale Komponente das war ja ein Punkt
der immer angesprochen wurde man darf
die Menschen nicht vergessen wir müssen
gucken wie wir sie mitnehmen wir müssen
gucken wie wir das finanzieren können
gerade beim Thema
wärmewende wie wie sieht es da aus nach
diesen Statements heute was hast Du
daraus gehört
ja das wüsste ich auch gerne genauer da
sagte Christian Lindner das sah noch
work im Progress
sehr viel
Konkretes gab es da vorhin noch nicht
ich habe es ja eben schon einmal gesagt
niemand wird allein gelassen das sagt
der Ricarda lang oder niemand wird im
Stich gelassen auch Christian Lindner
sprach davon dass das sozial gerecht vor
sich gehen würde aber viel mehr war da
bisher auch noch nicht rauszuhören
interessant ist da auch noch mal das ist
gerade gesagt die SPD
Lars Klingbeil hatte in dieser
dreierstellation jetzt tatsächlich den
allgemein letzten Teil der hat sich
wirklich nur einmal über die thematisch
über das rüber gebeugt hat noch einmal
das aufgemacht worüber in den letzten
zweieinhalb Tagen gesprochen worden ist
hat ein bisschen was zum zur Stimmung
gesagt dass man ringen musste aber jetzt
hoch zufrieden ist
dass alles noch ein bisschen besser
gelingen kann und dass man darauf
natürlich sich verständigen will die
Unsicherheiten zu sehen die die Leute
gerade umtreiben und dem gegensteuern
aber die
die inhaltlichen und die konkreten
Punkte die vorhin dargestellt wurden in
dieser Pressekonferenz die wurden
interessanterweise dem FDP-Chef und
einer der beiden grünen Chefin gelassen
das zeigt vielleicht auch noch mal dass
da tatsächlich der größte Redebedarf und
der größte kirmesbedarf bestanden hat
zwischen diesen beiden
Nicole lass uns noch mal über das Bild
sprechen dass die Regierung abgibt und
da hat man so ein bisschen das Gefühl
dass zwischen selbst und
Fremdwahrnehmung eine riesen Lücke
klafft also wir sehen einen äh
Oppositionsführer der sagt wir haben
eine
Regierungskrise dieses Land ist nicht
steuerbar und auf der anderen Seite
erleben wir Koalitionäre die sagen es
war total super dass wir uns jetzt mal
48 Stunden in Ruhe miteinander
austauschen konnten ähm
wer hat da jetzt das falsche Bild das
richtige Bild und an welcher Stelle muss
man denn aufpassen dass man den Bürgern
das richtige vermittelt
also ich würde jetzt von einer
Regierungskrise nicht reden dafür war es
auch heute Nachmittag zu früh man muss
da natürlich auch zu sagen das gehört zu
den Kernaufgaben eines
Oppositionsführers wie Friedrich Merz
ist ja ist so eine Vorlage und das muss
man auch sagen die die Ampel im
geliefert hat dadurch dass sie überhaupt
nicht zum Ende kam in ihrem
Koalitionsausschuss den diese Vorlage
auch zu verwandeln ähnliche Töne kamen
aus den anderen Oppositionsparteien auch
linke AFD ähm haben diese Chance
natürlich genutzt kritisch auf die Ampel
zu zeigen und zu fragen was ist da
eigentlich los
was natürlich
schön Färberei ist ist zu sagen wir
haben es genossen und jetzt mal vertieft
auszutauschen das hat wirklich Freude
gemacht dafür nimmt man sich von mir aus
zwei drei Tage Kabinett Klausur in
Meseberg hatten wir erst vor wenigen
Wochen dafür setzt man sich vielleicht
geplant ein Wochenende zusammen aber das
macht man natürlich nicht jedenfalls
nicht wenn man das wirklich so vor hat
sich vertieft auszutauschen wenn
zwischendurch quasi das halbe Kabinett
auch noch mal zu
Regierungskonsultationen in die
Niederlande fliegen muss wie gestern
Nachmittag das ist jetzt der Versuch des
umzudeuten das ist politische PR ähm
aber natürlich ist das nicht mal die
Hälfte der Wahrheit sondern man hat da
wirklich sehr sehr lange in dieser
Koalition gebraucht um sich in wichtigen
Punkten zu einigen und was auch finde
ich ganz wichtig ist ist
King weil und Ricarda lang haben weiter
darauf hingewiesen vergangenes Jahr sei
man ja sehr damit beschäftigt gewesen
die vor allem durch den Ukraine Krieg
ausgelösten Krisen zu meistern das ist
richtig der Koalitionsvertrag ist aber
vor Kriegsausbruch Monate vor
Kriegsausbruch geschlossen worden und
wenn man sich das heute angeguckt hat
und die letzten knapp anderthalb Jahre
im Dornröschenschlaf verbracht hätte
hätte man eben meinen können jetzt sind
die Koalitionsverhandlungen vorbei also
das ist schon sehr erstaunlich dass man
nach fast eineinhalb Jahren in einer
gemeinsamen Koalition solche Fragen noch
mal in so einer hochaktion klären musste
Nicole mit einer letzten Frage aus dem
aus dem Chat wäre ich noch bei dir viele
Punkte wurden genannt aber wenige Wege
zur Umsetzung wie wird denn das jetzt
alles konkret weitergehen
genau also diese sogenannte wärmewende
was ja vor allen Dingen im Moment
konkret die Frage ölgashaltung
Wärmepumpen meint da soll es jetzt ein
Gesetzgebungsprozess geben dasselbe gilt
für das was ich eben schon erwähnt habe
Planungs und Genehmigungsverfahren da
soll es ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren geben
das Autobahn ich sehe das mal als von
überragenden öffentlichen Interesse
deklariert werden und deshalb schneller
gebaut werden können das ist im Moment
das was wir wissen was in den nächsten
Tagen Wochen passieren wird dass das was
die drei da eben verkündet haben womit
die Frage natürlich nicht beantwortet
ist wie lange dieser Frieden jetzt hält
vielen Dank Nicole Diekmann dass du so
viele Stunden diese Koalition
Auseinandersetzungen oder wie auch immer
man es jetzt nennen mag Beratungen
begleitet hast und auch diesen Abschluss
dann jetzt heute Abend mit uns hier
eingeschätzt hast vielen Dank Nicole
Dieckmann nach Berlin tja liebe
Userinnen und User danke dass ihr und
sie dabei wart dass ihr kommentiert habt
wir blicken noch mal kurz auf die
Ergebnisse also die Ampel scheint sich
einig zu sein zumindest ist das der
Eindruck den man vermitteln will gerade
bei den Themen Klima und Verkehrsfragen
hat man sich geeinigt die Lkw-Maut z.B
soll erhöht werden um in die Bahn zu
investieren das ist nur eine von vielen
Maßnahmen um die Klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen um und um als Regierung gut in
die Zukunft zu gehen was den Klimawandel
angeht und auch was die eigene
Regierungsarbeit angeht wir werden sehen
ob der Plan so aufgeht sagen für heute
danke tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal